on the night that Harry done died they
promised him they would fight for
justice now finally the woman who admits
killing their son is being charged with
causing his death by dangerous driving
the heartache in this home has been
unbearable this is the first good news
they've had we set out so long ago that
we believed that we believed we believed
we've got the charge this is it I'm just
it's amazing absolutely amazing it's
amazing
Harry was 19 he was on his motorbike in
August when American answer coulis
pulled out of the US spy base at RAF
Croton in Northamptonshire where her
husband worked her lawyer says she was
driving on the wrong side of the road
when the collision happened
she claimed diplomatic immunity then
left the country mrs. sakulos who was
recently pictured back behind the wheel
was informed of the charging decision at
the same time as Harry's parents at the
start of this Harry's family were told
by the authorities here that they had
less than a 1% chance of getting justice
but after a relentless campaign on both
sides of the
take those odds may well have swung in
their favor their spokesperson paid
tribute to them their decency their
compassion their courage their tenacity
has been absolutely remarkable and it's
been truly humbling and inspiring to me
but in a statement and sakulos lawyer
said and is devastated by this tragic
accident and continues to extend her
deepest condolences to the family and
would do whatever she could to bring
Harry back she is a mother herself and
cannot imagine the pain of the loss of a
child
she has cooperated fully with the
investigation and accepted
responsibility but Ann will not return
voluntarily to the United Kingdom to
face a potential jail sentence for what
was a terrible but unintentional
accident they know their fight is far
from over
as the UK authorities begin the
extradition process the family say
they'll continue to appeal to the US
administration to do the right thing
Lisa del Sky News